kara is with us in Texas to start off
this hour hey Kara how are you hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up of course I had to get that in and I
am hoping that you'll be able to settle
I guess to pass that on my boyfriend and
I are heading down on we are just
finishing up over a year-long custody
battle over his son resulting in over
$100,000 in legal fees we did weather
over almost 100,000 $100,000 in a
custody no yes sir but we did everything
that we could to get to the other side
of it you know obviously the most
important thing is is you know being
able to be there for his son and keeping
our family together we just were
notified that his ex-wife is planning to
relocate to their home state which she
is allowed to do but of course that kind
of throws a kink in us being able to
continue down our baby steps we are
currently on baby step two and my
boyfriend has figured out that we've got
about $30,000 that we would need to pay
to be able to get our DTI to the right
point that we could buy another home
after we sell the one that we have now
if we should you know move is expected
that we're going to be able to do I
think that we need to pause on the baby
steps in order to save our perfect male
would be required for that move and as
well as to get everything in line
legally just to make sure that you know
we have everything taken care of to
decrease conflict moving forward and I'm
just wondering where you would think
that we should go from that so you're
moving to follow her in the kid correct
every time she moves well I mean so it's
there somewhere so you lost the custody
battle we didn't actually know we did it
so there's girls here up there we both
do so it's shared custody but they
basically they had moved here whenever
they were married for his job so they
always have this agreement that if she
wanted to go home she could go home
which i think is fair you know she wants
to move back to their family and I
didn't see his home town as well so we
would be moving close
searches family but it's just several
states away from the girl Rihanna
okay so and and if and if she were to go
and we didn't follow then obviously that
would change everything harass me well
it would make a very inconvenient to
have shared custody yeah correct and all
of this is after you spend a hundred
grand to get joint custody correct
bizarre so what is what is your
boyfriend make uh he takes home about
ninety five thousand and what do you
make I take home 50 okay and you
understand legally there is no we III do
understand that but that's legally it
not I don't know I don't I don't care
how you feed yeah I don't care about
your romance legally you have a
boyfriend that has a hundred thousand
dollars in debt and is following his
ex-wife so that he can be near his child
and he makes ninety five thousand a year
well and it's not it's not just his that
it seems that I've taken on as well
there are things that independently are
mine as a result of you know all of this
so you borrowed money to pay his legal
bills yes okay and when is it you're
getting married I mean I guess it's sort
of you each by you my mom could have a
conversation about that it's somewhere
out in the future this is something that
I have you're in a very precarious and
dangerous situation young lady no you
are I'm not joking around this and I'm
not being funny I mean you really are in
a mess because you've taken on all of
this and you have zero protections to
make sure that you you know if something
happens to this relationship that you're
not strung out to dry with these bills
and offer someone else's child that
you're not married to and so that the
the you know the benefit of marriage for
you is multiplied legal and relational
benefit
so you do whatever you want to do I am
duty-bound to answer questions on this
show because people call and ask me what
I would do and that's what you're asking
me what I would do and so if you were my
niece and you you know you probably are
that age and so I'm Uncle Dave and you
asked me and we weren't on the radio in
front of a whole bunch of people I would
tell you to get married or don't move
because you're going to get your you are
setting yourself up for all kinds of
problems here and I'm worried about you
and I care about you and I know you
think nothing will ever go wrong with
this young man but that's what his first
wife thought too and so you know you I'm
not saying he's a bad guy but things
happen in life and relationships end
sometimes and so you are in a very very
dangerous position and you're walking
around with your head in the clouds
acting like romance covers all this and
it just doesn't and I'm scared for you
I'm not trying to be mean to you I'm
just worried about you and so I know I
would not save up your money for him to
move to be with his kid now if you're if
your husband wants to be near his child
from another marriage then that's a
different discussion and the the call
you're making is perfectly reasonable
and so I would not move to another state
with this man if I were in your shoes
and that would be my advice to my niece
now you're not gonna follow that advice
I know that but I'm not also not going
to tell you because I care about you to
do something that I don't think is best
for you and I'm worried about you I
think you're in a bigger mess than you
think you are and so that that's what I
would tell you and then when you once
you've discovered that and and you've
settled that issue and it's not me and
your mama ragging on you that's not the
point the point is we're worried about
you and we care about you
and so once you settle that if you're
married then yeah your husband's got
$100,000 you and your new
but have $100,000 in legal bills from a
custody battle he had on a kid you care
about and he cares about and it's the
child of your husband's first marriage
and that's fine and that's a normal
process that people go through and now
you've got to work your way out of this
mess but uh yeah you save up a few
dollars and you'd make the move and then
you would begin to attack your debts but
you've got to have the money to make the
move if you're gonna make the move as a
couple but right now you're not a couple
in the laws eyes and so you're you're in
a precarious precarious situation I hope
you don't think I'm being unkind to you
because it's not my goal I'm just
worried about you kiddo and I don't want
I don't take the call from you three
years from now and the story went
sideways on you and you're in a mess I
don't want that for you as I get those
calls - in the last thirty years lots of
them
that's the problem with this show it's
my opinion and I'm gonna expert on my
opinion